my next guests have released one of the
hottest albums of the summer they are
really truly talented duo
it's called ungodly hour and it's
getting rave reviews they're signed to
their mentor Beyonce's labeled not too
shabby give it up for sisters Chloe and
Halle hi how are you I am so good I know
we've never officially met but we have
been on a song together my girls
which was organized by Michelle Obama to
raise money for girls education it was
such a cool thing and honestly that's
the first time I had heard of y'all and
I was like who are these chicks singing
right here and y'all were so young
you're so talented thank you much for
such huge fans of you something today
well that is awesome no I went down the
rabbit Hall of YouTube videos with y'all
last night I love your songs love your
music I love that it's like bringing
back what real R&B sounds like from
whatever I was in junior high that's
it's one of my favorite parts of your
sound is it kind of cool though speaking
Michelle Obama you know we all got to do
that together but she's been a big
supporter of girls he really has and
every time we pinch ourselves because as
you know she is as much of a goddess as
the world think she is so that's just
cool though that she's like seeing you
that must feel really cool to me to be
seen by someone like that is awesome but
speaking of powerful women
you're also signed to Beyonce's label my
fellow Texas girl I love her so I
understand she had no notes when she
heard your new album did that surprise
you cuz I feel like she's kind of like
me or ever all Texas women like let's do
it right let's get it done right and she
might be particular yes absolutely I
mean on our prior projects there would
definitely be more noise notes because
she's an amazing perfectionist and we
love that and admire that about her you
know she's always been one of our
biggest inspiration so when we presented
this album to her it was very little and
like minor things and we were like wow
she must really like it so we were very
very happy though
well you both you pushed the release of
your album your new AMA to honor George
Floyd how are you interpreting this
moment in our country because you're of
the younger generation and you're very
powerful and and
I think we've all been really impressed
with how the younger generation is
handling all of this how have you
specifically been handling it thank you
yes well the first couple of weeks when
everything was happening we were
definitely just very sad and I feel like
collectively in our community of our
black brothers and sisters it's like
this collective feeling of just trauma
when something like that happens because
for me personally I think of my little
brother we think of our dad that could
have been them so we just are trying to
do everything that we can to continue to
lift each other up with our voices and
demand justice for what's right I mean
our color of our skin should not be a
death sentence people deserve to live a
beautiful and long life just like
everyone else exactly I mean it's crazy
that's not a given saying to me well
Holly I'm you're set to play Ariel in
the live-action Little Mermaid which I'm
super stoked about that was one of my
favorites from childhood so what are you
excited for fans to see when it comes
out all I'm just excited for everyone to
see but kind of upgraded but also still
very close to home as the original I
mean the original was my favorite when I
was little as well I think everybody
really connects with Ariel in a way and
and resonates with the feeling of
wanting to be somewhere and and feel
like home is another place so we are
really excited for it and I just feel
very honored to take on that role to
show other black girls that they could
be princesses do ya representation I
agree agreed
I want to compliment you on something
too like watching you you both have such
different energies and vibes and they
both collide in such a cool way that is
so meaningful and I think it has to
happen and for in order for a duo to
actually work and I just it's very
inspiring to watch both of you you're
both so captivating in completely
different ways vocally aesthetically how
you move is your body like everything is
so different and yet it's it's like one
unit and it's really it's impressive
yeah much coming here I
well it's an it's incredible to watch it
it's awesome well thank you so much for
joining us ladies and everyone be sure
to check out their album ungodly hour
right now you're going on get it
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going